the earth is now starting to get
closer to being hospitable to people
like us or animals like us in the last
video we saw during the proterozoic eon
oxygen began to accumulate in the
atmosphere this actually caused this
first snowball earth and this mass
extinction of all the anaerobic species
but it made conditions suitable for
eukaryotic cells and maybe even more
important these eukaryotic cells were
able to form multicellular organisms and
we see where that starts right here on
this chart on this time clark
multicellular life starts right over
here and i want to be clear all of these
things are a bit moving targets as we
discover more things in the geological
record and we get more tools at our
disposal these numbers get tweaked but
they do give you a good sense based on
our current understanding of when these
things start to appear and coinciding
with multicellular life and this is
interesting in its own right because it
has its own meta-level effect on
evolution you actually start also having
sexual reproduction
sexual
reproduction
and what's interesting about this why
this has such a big impact on evolution
we talk about it a lot in the biology
playlist is before evolution variation
in dna had to be completely dependent
really on mutations and just random
movement around within dna or maybe some
viruses now it's sexual reproduction you
had kind of a a systematic mixing of dna
so that you got more variation in the
gene pool which allowed
more selection for or i guess you had
more very more variants to select for
and so you kind of had an acceleration
in the actual pace of evolution so
that's we're talking you know i've
looked at a bunch of sources from they
say 1.2 billion 1.5 billion a little bit
over a billion if you call a little bit
several hundred million years ago you
start having these multi-cellular life
forms and sexual reproduction
the other thing that we talked about in
the proterozoic eon is the accumulation
of oxygen allowed the ozone layer to
build up ozone is just three oxygen
atoms it is o3 and by
the end of the proterozoic eon so we're
talking i don't know maybe 550 million
years ago give or take tens of 400 or
maybe even a 100 million years these are
all moving targets the ozone layer was
dense enough to protect the land from uv
rays we talked about that in the last
video there's that the land that the
earth is being bombarded with uv rays
and the ozone layer is what the only
thing that really keeps us from being
seriously irradiated by the sun and
allows land animals to actually live and
so coinciding with that that time period
around 550 million years ago you start
to have life colonizing especially
significant life colonizing land
so life
colonizes land
colonizes
the land and this was kind of an
interesting when i first learned it it
was kind of an aha moment
you always assume that that kind of
trees and grasses are kind of part of
the background they come they come part
and parcel with land but it turns out
that animals colonized land before
plants did plants didn't come into the
picture until about
450 million years ago give or take a few
tens of millions of years
and so we're now entering the end of the
proterozoic
eon life has started to colonize land we
now have an ozone layer and what happens
and actually there's another snowball
glaciation or or snowball earth near the
end of the proter proterozoic air eon i
should say and there's a bunch of
theories about why it came about and
then why it disappeared maybe there were
volcanoes greenhouse gases who knows but
as we enter the end of that we start
seeing life begin to flourish and it
starts to really flourish as we enter
the fener
i have i always have trouble saying this
the phenerozoic eon and this right it's
not even labeled here the phenerozoic
eon is this
is this chunk of time right over here
and let me write it out so this right
over here is the
fenero
phanerozoic
the phenerozoic
eon and so this chart they kind of these
divisions right here are eons and then
they jump into instead of doing eons
here they then
break into eras errors are subsets of
eons they're hundreds of millions of
years so this is the paleozoic era the
mesozoic era and the cenozoic era and
that's actually our current era but
perhaps the most interesting well i
don't want to pick favorites here but
it's one of the most interesting times
in the geologic era is the first period
in the paleoz in the paleoz paleozoic
era era which is the first which is the
first era in the phanerozoic
eon and that's the cambrian period you
might have heard of it before the
cambrian period that's about this
this period of time
right over here
cambrian
and during this period of time the earth
experiences what what we call the
cambrian explosion and that's because
there's just this
explosion in the number of of of species
and and genera that existed the
biodiversity on the planet it might just
be that we had the ozone layer
protecting us things were colonizing
land it was an oxygen rich environment
we start seeing uh
complex multi-cellular organisms it's
about that time if you fast forward
maybe a few tens of millions of years
you start seeing the first fish the
first kind of
pre-amphibians or proto-amphibians you
fast forward a little bit as we get out
of the cambrian period we start seeing
we start seeing plants so they actually
draw it right over here on this land
plants or at this point right over here
and of course these are moving targets
depending on what we discover in the
fossil record
and for me
the big aha moment here so many of these
things that you consider fundamental to
uh what earth is a relatively recent
phenomenon
plants weren't on land until about 450
million years ago insects weren't on
land or did not even exist until about
400 million years ago reptiles didn't
exist until about 300 million years ago
so we are about we're about right over
here now mammals didn't exist until
about 200 million years ago birds didn't
exist until about 150 million years ago
the whole dinosaur age which we kind of
consider you know in our distant past
that's essentially the mesozoic era
right here
so this is the age of the dinosaurs
right over here when you look at your
time clock you can see it's a relatively
recent
time period and it actually ends with
are we currently believe a a huge rock a
six mile in diameter rock colliding with
what is now the yucatan peninsula in
mexico right off the coast of the
yucatan peninsula and it destroyed all
of the large land life forms especially
the dinosaurs and to put all of this in
in perspective and actually the thing
that really was an aha moment for me you
know it's okay plants are 450 million
years ago
grass i kind of views this fundamental
thing in nature but grass has only been
around for about i've seen multiple
estimates 40 to 70 million years grass
is a relatively new thing on the planet
flowers have only been around for 130
million years so there was a time where
you had dinosaurs but you did not have
flowers and you did not have
grass and so you fast forward all the
way and so when you look at this scale
it's kind of funny to look at they say
okay this is where this is the time
period where the dinosaur showed up this
brown this whole brown line is where the
mammal showed up so the dinosaur started
to show up along with the mammals
and then of course the dinosaurs died
out here our ancestors when the asteroid
when the when the giant rock hit the
earth must have been burrowed in holes
and were able to stash some food away or
who knows what and and didn't get fully
affected i'm sure some many most of the
large mammals were destroyed but it's
almost
it's humbling or almost humorous or
almost ridiculous when you look at this
chart is
they put a little dot you can't even see
it here a little but they say two
million years ago the first humans and
even this is being pretty generous when
they say first humans these are really
the first pre-humans the first humans
that are the same as us if if you took
one of those babies and you brought them
up in the suburbs and gave them haircuts
and stuff they would be the same thing
as we are those didn't exist until 200
000 years ago give or take 200 000 to
400 000 years ago i've seen estimates so
this is actually a very generous uh uh
a period of time to say first humans
it's actually 200 000 years ago and just
to give you an idea of of how new we are
and and how new our evolution is
it was only five million years ago and i
mentioned this in a previous video it
was only five million to go so this is
just to get a sense this is zero years
homo sapiens sapien only around four two
hundred thousand years the neanderthals
they were cousin species they weren't
our ancestors many people think they
were they were cousin species we come
from the same root although there are
now theories that uh they might have
remixed in with with with homo sapiens
so maybe some of us have uh
some neanderthal dna and it shouldn't be
viewed as an insult that you know they
had big brains well they didn't actually
have big brains they had big heads but
that seems to imply a big brain but who
knows we always tend to portray them as
somehow inferior but well i don't want
to get into the political correctness of
how to portray uh neanderthals
but anyway this is a very small
small period of time 200 if you go 2
million years then you get to kind of
the pre-human the pre-human ancestors
and our our our family tree only
diverged from the chimpanzees five
million years ago if you put if you draw
that on this clock right here it would
merely make it would be like two pixels
or maybe not even two pixels is when we
diverge from the chimpanzees so
hopefully that gives you a sense of
things at least at least for me it
really
puts things in perspective